[Musique]
en février dernier le footballeur
achrafat Kimi était au cœur de
l'actualité le défenseur du PSG achera
fakemi et visé par une enquête pour viol
accusations sa femme avec qui il a eu
deux enfants et qui partage sa vie
depuis 2018 a demandé le divorce j'ai eu
besoin de temps pour digérer ce choc et
avec l'annonce de cette séparation une
rumeur étonnante circule sur les réseaux
sociaux le jour du PSG aurait tout
anticipé partie d'un média ivoirien
l'info a très vite fait le buzz et
certains assurent que la star du ballon
rond aurait placé toute sa fortune au
nom de sa mère impossible donc pour son
ex-épouse de récupérer la moitié de ses
gains beaucoup d'internautes ont alors
applaudis cette démarche et un génie
Achraf mais alors un faux ou intox
achera fakchimi a-t-il vraiment tous les
gars à sa mère pour ne rien perdre à son
divorce on en parle ce soir dans TPMP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le média ivoirien dont on parle dans le
récap c'est un média qui a l'habitude de
propager des nouvelles comme ça autour
de fait l'actualité ils ont été ouf là
parce que c'est tout le monde la route
exactement alors c'est plutôt une fake
news voilà d'accord c'est ça voilà c'est
sûr ils Extrapol après il rentre sa
crédible donc tout le monde reprend
exactement bien c'est pas ça mondial
c'est pas la
vérités de leur divorce qui est en cours
mais voilà chacun des deux a du
patrimoine il a un énorme patrimoine en
70 millions d'euros et elle elle a un
patrimoine aussi 3 millions d'euros mais
c'est pas vrai qu'il a mis au nom de sa
mère ça ne serait pas possible ni en
Espagne ni au Maroc ni en France donc
voilà c'est une fake news on peut leur
dire bravo parce que ils ont réussi à
faire croire ça au monde entier quoi
c'est comme deux jumeaux qui est
derrière je dis bravo on peut leur dire
aussi des mecs qui ont fait le
incroyable c'était incroyable c'est
insupportable de quoi bah moi je leur
dis pas bravo à ces gens-là ceux qui
créent des trucs comme ça qui inventent
des choses moi je trouve ça
insupportable plutôt marrant c'est pas
un truc méchant
c'est pas un truc méchant ça va
franchement c'était ça on distingue que
c'est pas très vrai ça leur répondit
les gars ils peuvent pas faire le
contraire si tous les jours il y a plein
de coups de journalistes qui l'ont
repris
le problème du foot même fin des des
journalistes le problème surtout c'est
que les pouces s'en prend plein la
tronche sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est que tout le monde dit ah ouais
elle est intéressée pour son argent
c'est
un peu moins un peu moins cool parce que
déjà son mari est accueil
bien sûr en plein la gueule
tu as fait une très bonne intervention
vraiment vraiment
avec le poignet gros comme ça
spécialiste est-ce divorce soit il a
prévu les choses
alors ça c'est impossible ça c'est un
peu faim voilà en France quand on
divorce soit on a un contrat de mariage
et tout est écrit par avance et donc ce
qui était à lui reste à lui ce qu'il a
acquis au sein de la communauté lui
revient sauf s'il a acheté des choses
avec sa femme s'il a dit j'ai acheté la
maison de mon principal avec ma femme là
on partage et dans son et dans son cas
comme c'est un garçon qui a un beau
train de vie elle pourra toujours
demander ce qu'on appelle une prestation
compensatoire quand vous avez vous êtes
avec un garçon qui vous a amené à
Courchevel l'hiver à Saint-Barth voilà
février et cetera en fait l'état vous
enfin la justice vous permet de
continuer à vivre un peu comme ça
pendant quelques années et des enfants
de verser une pension alimentaire avec
les deux enfants ça c'est obligé
et pour que les enfants gardent le même
train de vie en fait c'est magnifique
j'ai découvert sur vos images elle est
magnifique sa femme donc s'il a acheté
des biens s'il a acheté des biens au nom
de grande actrice espagnole hein
très très belle il achète des biens au
nom de sa maman ça c'est un moment oui
bah alors
tu peux le faire
tu es marié exactement
[Rires]
un appartement je voulais qu'elle ait
une maison qu'elle est un jardin à son
nom ou tu l'as acheté pour toi et puis
après non je l'ai acheté à mon nom
c'était pour éviter c'est pour éviter
les taxes d'habitation
avec ma mère elle avait aucune rentrée
d'argent donc j'ai payé les taxes
d'habitation tout ça et j'ai acheté je
fais pareil avec ma mère mais vous avez
bien fait parce que c'est l'honneur
[Rires]
ils étaient avec des pommes là je
regarde c'est mon nom tu vois non non
non t'inquiète pas ouais ça va je te le
dis j'ai fait pareil ça va vous avez
acheté une maison aussi pour vos parents
oui je t'en pose des questions
non mais je trouve ça magnifique moi ce
serait mon rêve le pouvoir
n'aime pas les habitations non mais
voilà c'est ma chance
pas ils sont gâtés et tu pourras leur
demander hein tu le sais ils sont gâtés
voilà oui j'ai une question pour les
spécialistes divorce si c'est la femme
qui demande le divorce de son propre
chef mais que le mari a pas merdé est-ce
qu'elle a le droit à une compensation
alors en France il n'y a plus de divorce
donc elle a quand même une compensation
toujours
même si c'est elle qui veut partir
actuellement sur quel régime puisqu'ils
sont en Espagne ils sont en France ils
voyagent tout le temps ils vivent en
France ils travaillent en France je
crois qu'il est au camp
je pense qu'ils sont sur le soleil sous
le soleil justice française puisqu'ils
en France vu que la France est
pratiquement taxé de là alors attention
en Amérique c'est 100 % du perd tout
hein en Amérique c'est terrible
aux États-Unis vous pouvez même ne pas
être marié mais si vous avez vécu
ensemble un certain nombre d'années
considère que vous êtes marié comme
mariés
mais il faut savoir quand même et ne pas
oublier vis-à-vis du fixe dans du
fiscaliste
ça fait de la barre fixe cette semaine
tout ce que vous gagnez en France vous
payez des impôts en France et tout est
déclaré en France bien sûr ou que tu
sois c'est bien ce que tu dis
franchement non bravo bravo bravo bravo
en tout cas pour vous dire relaxer une
connerie et voilà je vous dire pour moi
il y a qu'une chose qui triomphera
toujours c'est l'amour
quand même faites des papiers avant quoi
pas après
c'est bien d'avoir un spécialiste
regardez c'est comme vous regardez
comment vous avez prévu ah bah j'ai pris
ils font vraiment des contrats de
mariage
ça choque personne
de travail tout est prévu si vous foute
une fois deux fois trois fois
ça veut dire que tu mets j'ai le droit
de tromper ma femme 4 fois par an
c'était trompé officiellement elle
prenait 100 millions de dollars c'est
marqué sur le contrat par mois non non
une fois
moi j'ai fait autre chose moi quand
j'étais marié avec Daniel Moreau j'ai
mis comme une rançon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]